hi I'm David Newland and thanks for
visiting my poster it's all my project
is about a new way of measuring order
and disorder in tumors and how this can
be applied as a new diagnostic tool to
improve precision medicine to start the
architectural organization of cells
inside a tumor is highly disorganized
such that most people would say that the
arrangement of cells is random however
there's a difference between randomness
and disorder when we when we say that a
system is random what we are saying is
that what we're assuming is that we have
sufficient knowledge of what is
non-random in that system such that we
can say that both you know this tumor
the cells are arranged randomly
however you know from engineering
computer science we know that you know
the entire premise of encrypting email
and digital information that sent over
Internet right is premise upon our
ability to actually make something you
know something that's ordered to look so
disordered right that it's you know
incomprehensible and thus random okay
and so there is existing evidence if you
look at figure one that tumors do have
an inherent order to them that we have
been aware for a long time this is why
tumors can be graded by a pathologist as
grade 1 grade 2 or grade 3 being the
most say aggressive and the grading
system of tumors is based upon the
features such as nuclear morphology you
know the pink or purple mists of the
hematoxylin and eosin stain in the
tissue excuse me and other factors and
so and furthermore pathologists are able
to classify tumors according to their
histo
biological subtype for example a
pathologist can identify a tumor as you
know a adenoid carcinoma while another
tumor might be a you know cystic right
carcinoma another one might be
metaplastic okay so metaplastic
carcinomas or metaplastic breast cancers
are ones in which the structure
architecture within a tumor right is
highly variable as it is not just one
type or one recurring type of structure
it's multiple ones mixed together right
so it's very hard to can be very hard to
classify and metaplastic
tumor right but the fact that there is
tumor grading and histopathological
subtypes right is strong indication that
though tumors are highly disorganized
right there are recurring themes and
regularities that scientists can
identify and use to stratified cancers
in to varying degrees of say
aggressiveness or severity so the
purpose of my research is to refine that
ability such that we can classify these
tumors even further into more specific
groups that allows us to then determine
you know which types of tumors respond
to therapy better what type of therapy
and you know which type tumors
ultimately relapse more than others in
order to do this for metaplastic tumors
I created what's called the quadrant
slope index so in order to if you look
at theater to write the the way you
would do the Quadra slope index or QSI
is to divide the entire image into a
grid of uniform squares okay and then
each of these squares you then further
divided into you know four even squares
right with you know a two-dimensional XY
coordinate and so with each of these
within each of these X Y you know
quadrants or each of these squares has
four quadrants right that you know
result from an XY axis right you can
simply trace the
the longest length of each nuclei right
and the slope of that line will either
point up right be positive slope or
point down be a negative slope right
with the bottom of image being the
reference ok the horizontal parallel
with or a horizontal x-axis so in this
way in each of these quadrants you can
count the number of you know upward
slopes and a number of downward slopes
ok and such that you can divide a one
over the other right such as in Figure
two see in this way not only can you
generate a number okay for each quadrant
that is in each of these squares in the
larger grid right these numbers can also
be turned into a color right in the form
of a heat map so in this way by the
Quadra slope index method right you can
generate a new view of a tumor image if
you look at figure three here's a
hypothetical example in figure 3 a here
is you know typically a cartoon of what
you know a metaplastic tumor would look
like right this is a garbled arrangement
of cells of different types and
orientations in figure 3 B here's a
hypothetical grid that has been created
and each of the red axis right is one of
the squares in the in the grid of the
whole tumor all right and each of the
quadrants resulting from the red axis
right can become a color so in this way
if you look at a figure 3a right it was
purposely drawn to have an obvious
pattern of cells in the upper right hand
corner of 3a that is the spindly
stretchy elongated cells that flow
together you know like a stream of water
say a stream of liquid okay and so
that's sort of easily detected that's
who think by the human eye and also by
the quadrant slope index method right as
seen in figure 3
see right the the green squares right
labeled as over obvious right however a
lot of people are surprised that there's
another hidden I guess order in figure 3
a that is the bottom right hand corner
right you have these oval shaped cells
that are arranged in a row right but to
the human eye is really hard to pick
that out okay especially if you're
looking under a microscope as
pathologists do or now even on the
screen as pathologists in the United
States are allowed to diagnose and you
know according to the FDA now this is
several months ago diagnosed you know
the tumors and tissues by looking at
computer screens right and so so people
are often surprised to realize that wow
yeah so figure three a does have two
regions of orderliness right the obvious
one and the the letter H in three C
figures 3 C that is the hidden right
region order right and so that's the
power of this quantitative method the
Quadra slope index and that because it
is calculated with the help of a
computer that can you know kept late new
things very quickly and you know at a
high rate we're able to turn the
features right the orderliness and
disorderliness of a tumor into numbers
okay and for the more we can aid the
pathologist in by visualizing the degree
of order and disorder right in each
tumor right so this allows for more
refined stratification of tumors okay
instead of just grade 1 grade through to
grade 3 we can create grade 1 a 1 B 1 C
2 a 2 B 2 C etc right and so this is
exciting in that this method has the
potential to enhance the precision
diagnostic oncology so that when you
your physician takes a biopsy of your
tumor and sends it to a pathologist the
pathologist can give a more specific
recommendation as to the stage of your
disease say and which therapy would best
help you with the fewest side effects
it's also exciting in that you know we
the next stage is to test whether if we
can calculate you know the QSI instead
of use a computer what is the minimum
number of Q sis or squares right and
make you more image that we can
calculate and still accurately predict
the outcome right of that that patient
at that sample that would be highly
useful in the case where people can only
have access to low-tech diagnostic tools
whether that's in the case of developing
nations or when you know the hurricane
shuts down electricity right and we you
know our batteries our apps our
computers run out of electricity what do
we do right you know then we rely and
the old school method of just you know
pen and paper so to speak and so when we
when we have a large you know there's a
lot of large archive data sets of tumor
images that also correspond with the
patient data as to no age and Z stage
and how long they lived and how long
they live before relapse happen right
now such clinical information and so
having that data we can perform the QSI
measures and create a benchmark right a
table such that you know somebody who
whether they calculated the QSI using
computer or by hand
they have a table in which to
interpolate right the severity of a
patient's tumor right and what the
recommended you know treatment options
are right in light of the QSI index
right so this is very exciting and we
are in the process of testing this on
breast cancers but it is applicable to
many other types of cancers and even
normal tissues that are non cancerous
but but are have an affected morphology
due to disease exposure or some other a
challenge or insult as it is as is
referred to by scientists so that's a
summary of my talk thank you for
listening feel free to reach out to me
my email address is d h
and GUI the end at LBL gov okay that's
the end I think I went over I'm yeah I
met